[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and we're thrilled to have you here
we're so excited about what the future
holds and we've invested a lot to make
you successful with Google Cloud so you
can build applications faster and more
secure than ever
you may have heard Thomas kurian talk
about how we offer prescriptive Guidance
with an opinionated approach to solve
developer velocity challenges in today's
session I'm going to show you how
exactly we do this by highlighting how
Google Cloud lets you deliver secure
applications in an open manner even
though working remotely has become the
norm working faster remotely and across
distributed teams continues to be a
challenge typical friction points
include onboarding Road employees
setting up Dev and test environments and
long build times just to name a few
when it comes to security code and data
exfiltration risks are key
this is especially true in sensitive and
regulative environments
customers tell us that current solutions
to secure Dev environments can add
developer friction to the experience
for example streaming-based Solutions
May introduce unwanted latency
in running your specific containers may
not be fully supported
solving developer velocity challenges
requires a two-pronged approach
how do we not only make it easier for
developers to build applications but
also easy for it admins to securely
scale in Dev environments
to address this
I'm excited to announce the availability
of cloud workstations
think of cloud workstations as providing
pre-configured but customizable
developer environments in the cloud with
your favorite dev tools pre-installed
and up to date
Cloud workstations come with multi-ide
support such as IntelliJ Pi charm Ryder
sea lion code OSS and others as part of
this fully managed experience and since
Cloud workstations can run inside the
same network as your other resources
you don't need to emulate services or
databases which Can Save hours by
developing and running code in your
staging environment Cloud workstations
enables consistent developer definitions
among developers with all environments
defined via containers
fixing the well it works on my machine
problem
increasing developer velocity is
incomplete without having the right
security controls in place for remote
Developers
this is why Cloud workstations has
Enterprise grade security requirements
built right in
this starts with VPC service controls
where you can limit developer access to
sensitive areas you can update or patch
your environments so that developers get
the most up-to-date version
and you can also use a fully private
Gateway so that only trusted users
within your network have Dev access
Cloud workstations can provide security
capabilities as you code which can be
extended to other parts of your software
supply chain from build dependency
management to deployment
on the product side we are taking those
efforts to the next level with the
launch of software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield provides a
fully managed end-to-end software supply
chain security
this starts with the IDE and includes CI
CD pipelines deploy time policies and
runtime security posture
so while you're focused on writing code
software delivery Shield or SDS is
helping to make sure your organization's
security policy is consistently enforced
across the software delivery process
enabling you to develop faster
specifically SDS adds new security
capabilities in four major areas
first to shift left into the IDE we are
launching Cloud code Source protect
a private preview IDE extension which
helps you better understand open source
vulnerabilities and licenses to go
faster by avoiding costly and
frustrating rework down the road
second when it comes to securing
dependencies we're excited to announce
our assured open source software service
it scans for known vulnerabilities
analyze and fuzz tests over 250 packages
across Java and python
these packages are built using Google
secured pipelines to help external
dependency risks and come with
remediation slas
third
SDS helps secure CI CD with Cloud build
which now supports salsa level 3.
for those unfamiliar salsa is an
emerging standard that incorporates best
practices for software supply chain
integrity
Cloud build provides verifiable build
provenance to help you trace a binary to
its source and build process to prevent
tampering improve the artifact you're
using is legit
fun fact Providence is not just
available for containers but for Java
Maven packages as well
lastly SDS can extend security
protection into Cloud run and gke
Cloud run security panel now includes
software supply chain security insights
this provides information such as salsa
level on the running container images
build provenance and service
vulnerabilities
to help protect kubernetes workloads gke
security posture management provides
opinionated foundational guidance into
your gke clusters
we do this by providing detailed
security assessments actionable
remediation advice and scanning for OS
vulnerabilities in your running images
we're integrating the platform to
further help drive speed and efficiency
for instance
Cloud deploy can make continuous
delivery for cloud run much simpler
promote from pre-prod to prod conduct
rollbacks and manage gate promotion
approvals in a cohesive and intuitive
interface
with the new Cloud run Integrations you
can connect Cloud run with Google cloud
services fast
for example configuring domains with a
load balancer or connecting to a redis
cache is now as easy as a single click
and by the way we have more scenarios on
the way
with these enhancements you no longer
need to be an expert in scaling securing
or managing your pipelines or connecting
to other Google cloud services we've
also been focused on helping remove
barriers across our data platform
allowing developers to build data-driven
applications faster
after all data often Powers the most
impactful experiences
we're providing integration with vertex
AI our AIML platform
this enables inferencing directly within
the database transaction
in addition we're announcing in preview
spanner integration with vertex AI
this integration allows data scientists
to build their models easily in vertex
AI and developers to access those models
using the SQL query language
it's a great time to be a developer
because software is enabling businesses
to reimagine how they're providing more
engaging experiences
in doing this with the peace of mind
that security is embedded at every step
of the way and everything I just
described was designed to help you focus
on what you love writing code fast
we're excited to create this future
together thanks for joining us
[Music]
Yang VP of cloud AI industry Solutions
and I'm sudhir husband I'm senior
director of product management for data
analytics at Google Cloud the last few
years have led us to a Tipping Point
with AI adoption where we have seen the
impact of AI across more and more
organizations and more and more use
cases
organizations for many Industries and
varying level of ml expertise are
solving business critical problems with
AI from creating compelling customer
experience to optimizing operations to
automating routine tasks these
organizations learn to innovate faster
and ultimately get ahead in the
marketplace
but how do they get there AI is hard
fundamentally hard
first a challenge start with data it is
the challenge to manage this growth and
complexity it is a challenge to prepare
data for AI and ml usage
second AI expertise is scarce how many
AI experts do you need to get your first
model into production what about the
next set of use cases
and finally if you have all the pieces
in place the road from prototype to
production can still take months if not
years
how can you scale faster with confidence
I'm proud to announce the general
availability of big lake to help you
break the data silos and unify your data
lakes and warehouses Big Lake will also
support Apache Iceberg which is becoming
the standard for open source table
formats for your data leaks and soon we
will also add support for other formats
like Delta Lake and hoodie our built-in
support for Apache spark in bigquery
will allow data practitioners to create
bigquery stored procedures unifying
their work in spark with their SQL
Pipelines
as of today over 800 software Partners
power their applications using our data
cloud and 40 data platform Partners like
DBT data IQ and Tableau support bigquery
through certified Integrations
and customer adoption continues to grow
fueled by the ecosystem initiatives like
data Cloud Alliance
now we know
80 to 90 percent of data you have today
is unstructured this includes your
images your video files your audio files
today we are announcing support for
unstructured data in bigquery through
object tables object tables enable you
to take advantage of common security and
governance across your data you can now
build data products that unify
structured and unstructured data in
bigquery today we are announcing support
for unstructured data in bigquery
through object tables object tables
enable you to take advantage of common
security and governance across your data
you can now build data products that
unify structured and unstructured data
in bigquery
this makes bigquery One-Stop solution to
store manage and process all types of
data at global scale so in a nutshell to
overcome data complexity challenges we
are bringing lakes and warehouses
together with big lake and providing
support for open formats we are unifying
structured semi-structured and
unstructured data workloads into
bigquery
openness unification and Trust are the
foundation of intelligent data-driven
organization Google Cloud addresses this
challenge by offering a wide range of
capabilities that can increase the reach
of AIML to more users and help your
scarce resource your data scientists to
achieve greater productivity
organizations can start with our
out-of-box API like translation
transcription and many more where
developers can directly apply Google's
state-of-art AI to quickly solve real
world problems without the need to build
AI models themselves when you want to
work with your own data to build custom
models vertex AI offer a range of ml
tools to help you to build deploy and
manage ml models
this includes the ability to start from
scratch to create a fully custom models
were built on top of or one of our
existing models and then fine-tune them
for your particular needs starting with
bigquery ML a SQL interface that unlocks
ml capability for data analysts and
simple ways to be able to build and
train their models
as you have heard from sudir bigquery
will support unstructured data which
means bigquery ml would also work with
unstructured data you can now bring your
own model or use a model that's
pre-trained by Google directly on
bigquery object tables the results can
be stored and managed in bigquery for
further analysis or deplorative vertex
AI for real-time prediction for users
who want more control over ml
we recently announced exciting
announcement for automl workflows which
allows you selectively modify each step
in the model building and the deployment
process and be able to tweak custom
tweaks for for your automl and giving
your work control working with automl we
will start with structured data and
expand support to unstructured data in
the coming months
tabnet is a powerful algorithm developed
by Google researchers that leverage
neural nets for tabular data today we're
adding tabnet to workflow to make it
easier for organization to work at a
massive scale without sacrificing the
explainability or accuracy
for some workloads faster is what it's
all about
I am excited to introduce vertex AI
Vision a revolutionary end-to-end
computer vision application development
service
that helps you to be able to reduce the
amount of time it takes to build
computer vision application from days to
minutes at a fraction of the cost was it
easy to use drag and drop interface and
pre-trained model for common tasks
vertex AI vision is the One-Stop shop to
build deploy manage computer vision
application so how did they get there
scaling data in AI across an
organization first requires strong data
governance and management and secondly
in order to move from data to AI
efficiently across use cases
organizations also need to streamline
end-to-end processes from preparing data
to building deploying and maintaining
machine learning models
further these capabilities we are
announcing various Innovations to
dataplex our intelligent data fabric
dataplex helps organizations centrally
manage and govern distributed data today
we are introducing
data lineage so you can get complete
end-to-end lineage from ingestion of
data to analysis to machine learning
models data quality will enable you to
gain confidence in your data which is
critical to get accurate predictions and
more importantly dataplex is now fully
integrated with big league so you can
now manage fine-grained access across
the organization at scale let's recap
for a moment we have discussed how our
data Cloud helps you unify data to
address the challenges of data
complexity and silos with this
organizations are well positioned to
adopt AI with built-in services for a
wide range of use users and use cases
this is critical to mitigating the
skills Gap Challenge and embedding AI
into your organization and finally
end-to-end data governance and
centralized ml Ops helps you scale AI so
you can address more use cases and drive
results across your business we hope you
have enjoyed the session thank you so
much for attending
foreign
y Goodman's general manager and VP of
engineering for databases at Google
cloud and I'm excited to share with you
what's next for Builders and data
engineers at Google Cloud our mission is
to accelerate every organization's
ability to digitally transform
and a large part of that is helping
customers innovate faster with the
unified open and intelligent data
platform
we do this by focusing on four key areas
first a unified and integrated data
Cloud for all your data
second a commitment to openness
leveraging open source and Open
Standards
third infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workflows
and lastly empowering Builders to be
more productive and impactful
let's start with the first Focus area
creating a unified and integrated data
Cloud if you're operational and
analytical data
the way we've built our core services
such as Cloud spanner bigtable alloy DB
MPEG query is truly differentiated
these Services leverage Google's common
infrastructure which is unique in the
industry
our highly scalable distributed storage
system
are disaggregated compute and storage
and are high performance google-owned
Global networking allow us to provide
industry leading tightly integrated
operational and analytical data services
building on this customers need to have
easy movement of data within the data
cloud
we heard you and that's why we announced
in preview data stream for bigquery
data stream for bigquery provides easy
replication of data from operational
database sources such as loadb postgres
MySQL and Oracle directly into bigquery
this is special because we worked
closely with the bigquery team to
develop an optimized integration to
replicate database updates in real time
at very low latency
setup is just a few simple clicks to
continue on this theme of easy data
replication from operational databases
for use cases like analytics event-based
architectures compliance or archival
we're announcing today in preview
bigtable change streams
this capability joins our already
existing recently launched spanner
change streams
with chain streams you can track rights
updates and delete so that they can be
replicated to Downstream systems in real
time the second Focus area is our
continued commitment to open source and
Open Standards for increased flexibility
and portability without vendor lock-in
we offer many services that are fully
compatible with the most popular open
source engines such as MySQL postgres
and redis postgres an open source
database has emerged as the leading
alternative to Legacy proprietary
databases because of its Rich
functionality ecosystem extensions and
Enterprise readiness
it's not surprising that millions of
users across Industries have adopted
postgres
we're focused on making Google Cloud the
best place to run your postgres
workloads we offer you not one not two
but three fully managed services that
support the postgres interface
first Cloud SQL for postgres
it is our Enterprise ready fully managed
relational database service
you get the same experience of Open
Source postgres with the strong
manageability availability and security
capabilities of cloud SQL
and you can use the same service apis to
also manage your MySQL and SQL Server
databases
second alloy DBS are fully managed
postgres compatible database service
ready for your top tier workloads and
for modernizing your legacy proprietary
databases in the cloud
in our performance tests alloyodb is
more than four times faster than open
source postgres and two times faster
than Amazon's comparable postgres
compatible service for transactional
workloads
it also delivers up to 100 times faster
analytical queries than standard
postgres
and open isn't just about our technology
it's also about developing an open
ecosystem of Partners alloy DB already
integrates with many leading Technology
Solutions and has a fast-growing
ecosystem of partners with expertise
ready to support your deployments and
finally we've also added a postgres
interface for spanner our transformative
relational database with unlimited
global scale strong external consistency
and up to five nines availability
with the postgres interface for spanner
developers can take advantage of
familiar tools and skills from the
postgres ecosystem
and to further democratize access to
spanner we recently announced a free
trial to give Builders an easy way to
try out spanner at no cost
get started building with spanner today
the third Focus area is around how we
are infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workloads we use Ai and ml
across our database Technologies to make
our services more intelligent
capabilities such as Cloud SQL cost
recommenders and alloy DB autopilot
enable dbas and devops teams to manage
performance and capacity for large
fleets of databases
in addition to infusing Ai and ml into
our databases we're providing
integration with vertex AI our Ai and ml
platform to enable model inferencing
directly within the database transaction
I'm therefore excited to announce today
in preview the integration of vertex AI
with spanner
you can now use a SQL query in spanner
to call a model and vertex AI
with this integration both alloy DB and
now spanner can simply call vertex AI
models using SQL in operational
transactions allowing data scientists to
build their models easily in vertex Ai
and developers to access these models
using the SQL query language our final
Focus area is around empowering Builders
to be more productive with Innovative
one-of-a-kind developer experiences
we've introduced Cloud SQL query
insights for postgres and MySQL in
addition we make Cloud SQL cost
recommenders generally available and
introduce postgres system insights in
preview
today we're excited to announce the
preview of security and performance
recommenders for cloud SQL so now let's
hear from Scott Wong VP of
infrastructure at Credit Karma to learn
how they've reduced operational burden
and cost with Google's data cloud
Scott welcome
we're glad to have you here today
thanks for having me Andy excited to be
here
tell me Scott who is Credit Karma and
why did you choose Google Cloud
in 2007 Credit Karma was founded during
the last housing crisis with a mission
to be the consumer technology platform
focused on helping our members Achieve
Financial progress and over the last 15
years we've really built this around
free credit scores providing over 4
billion credit scores to our consumers
across the US UK and Canada and today
nearly 130 million members use our
product but Financial progress term our
members means much more than just credit
reports we are the go-to destination for
everything related to financial goals
and to provide this we provide
personalized data-driven insights to our
members to feel more confident about
their major money decisions and at the
center of these insights is our data
models and Data Systems all being
powered by Google cloud services today
how are you using Google's data Cloud
today for your key use cases and what
are some business benefits you've
achieved by moving to Google Cloud
one we really focus on making our data
scientists as efficient as possible
and that meant simplifying access to our
users feature store as well as deploying
their models as quickly as possible
to give you some set of scale today we
deploy over 700 models a week as opposed
to pre-cloud it was almost 10 a quarter
additionally in experimentation we do
over 7x more experiments today than we
did before cloud
and with the help of bigtable and
bigquery we have 10x more features
deployed daily through our batch data
these gains can be attributed to what we
call our unified model training powered
by bigquery bigtable dataflow and
Google's AI platform
thank you so much for that conversation
Scott I really appreciate you joining us
today
thank you for having me Andy and I
enjoyed being part of Google next
as you can see from always spoken about
today the future of data has endless
possibilities
tune in to all our sessions and next for
more details on the announcements you
heard today
thank you enjoy the rest of next
[Music]
hello I'm Sachin Gupta vpgm for
infrastructure at Google Cloud
the roles of Enterprise Architects and
developers are evolving
not only do you have to keep the lights
on you are expected to stay on top of
the ever-changing trends and
technologies that create business value
and you have to do all of this while
lowering costs and improving performance
so it infrastructure runs quickly and
smoothly
Your Role is critical to a successful
transformation with Google Cloud you can
innovate faster and more easily while
optimizing costs we know organizations
like yours still have a lot of
infrastructure to migrate and we are
committed to helping you migrate more
securely and efficiently Global
customers and local Partners like Palo
Alto Networks h m and Major League
Baseball rely on us to deliver scalable
High performing highly available Cloud
infrastructure and services AI is in our
DNA
from AI powered search to YouTube
recommendation engines and Google
Assistant Cloud TPU V4 delivers industry
leading ml training performance and
scale with six terabits per second
interconnect you can run large-scale
training workloads up to 80 faster and
up to 50 percent cheaper compared to
Alternatives we're also announcing new
A2 Ultra gpus built on nvidia's A180 gig
gpus with high-speed memory today we are
announcing a new industry Consortium the
open xla project that will unite an
ecosystem of leading machine learning
compiler Technologies and accelerate and
simplify machine learning Innovation
these open source AI contributions
enable you to take your AI idea and turn
it into reality easily and at low cost
Cloud armor is another security
innovation that provides Advanced ml
power DDOS and Waf protection for web
apps services and apis
it has prevented some of the largest
DDOS attacks on the planet with zero
impact to customers recently the largest
https attack was staged against a cloud
armor customer
it was 76 percent larger than anything
previously reported the equivalent of
Wikipedia's daily requests in 10 seconds
and the customer experience no impact
and for regulated Industries with
stringent and Country specific
requirements we offer controls to meet
your digital sovereignty objectives
since transformation takes different
forms for different Industries we
partner with customers to build
industry-leading innovative solutions in
media and entertainment we provide
solutions to customers like you next
with streaming built on the same Google
infrastructure we've tested and tuned to
serve YouTube's two billion users
globally
to get a better picture of how our media
and entertainment industry customers
innovate with Google Cloud I'm proud to
introduce senior vice president
technical infrastructure of Major League
Baseball Truman boys
[Music]
[Applause]
Major League Baseball's technology
mission is to connect with our fans our
infrastructure team has historically
maintained applications on-prem and now
we have unlimited compute from the
public cloud and this allowed us to shut
down four data centers modernize all of
our infrastructure and to spin things up
rapidly
and in the off season we scale it back
Google's Cloud helps us to understand
the entire fan journey and artificial
intelligence allows us to derive a
better connection to them we're able to
have personalized content with that fan
it gets richer over time as we learn
more about them
working with Google we're preserving the
history of baseball going back into the
1940s and we're able to make highlights
available to our fans Google Cloud hosts
all of these video clips for us
and now we have an opportunity to enrich
this format beyond what it is today
we're looking to modernize the entire
platform that we have and move into
delivery through media CDN
Major League Baseball and Google Cloud
are connecting with our fans so that
experience is happening in venue as well
as a digital experience and we're not
getting out of the park
thank you so much Truman it is amazing
to see how MLB is innovating for The Fan
Experience leveraging Google
Technologies like AI media CDN and the
reliability and elasticity of our Global
infrastructure
we've shared a number of ways in which
we've built our infrastructure to enable
transformation
but we also continue to build Solutions
and products tuned to support your top
workloads and data applications
and we've optimized these for both
performance and cost
one example of this is Google Cloud
VMware engine
VMware engine is a fully managed native
Google service that helps you lift and
shift your VMware applications to Google
Cloud faster and easier
we are the first external provider to
support vmware's Cloud Universal program
which makes it easier for you to migrate
to the cloud
and with built-in point-and-click
migration tools and our instant
provisioning feature you can get
workloads running in your private cloud
in less than one hour we are continuing
to scale VMware engine by increasing
support from 64 to 96 nodes per private
Cloud all with four lines of
availability in a single site and a
dedicated 100 gigabit per second Network
this provides high performance and
reliability for your most demanding
production workloads another example of
workload optimization is a recently
announced Google Cloud
high performance Computing toolkit HPC
toolkit is an open source tool from
Google that helps you quickly and easily
create repeatable TurnKey HPC clusters
next I'm really excited to announce
c3vms
it is the first VM on the market to
feature the latest generation of Intel
Sapphire Rapids processors and is built
on new Intel Google co-designed
infrastructure processing units or ipus
all of this together means
differentiated performance security
isolation and flexibility
C3 is the first VM in our Fleet with 200
gigabits per second low latency
networking to support a variety of
workloads such as data processing web
serving and high throughput HPC
workloads moving on to another product
built to Leverage The ipu Google cloud
hyperdesk is the next generation of
block storage which will be available on
both compute engine and gke
we are decoupling block storage
performance from the VM allowing you to
tune your storage performance to your
workload needs our new flexible
committed use discounts or Flex Cuts can
make it easier to save and manage costs
across teams by giving you region and VM
family flexibility with autoclass
customers like redvis are reducing
storage costs and achieving Better Price
predictability in a simple way
it automatically transitions objects to
cooler storage based on the last time
they were accessed and transitions to
standard storage upon access our new
migration Center can reduce complexity
time and cost
by providing key capabilities in
migrating and modernizing to Virtual
machines containers or serverless
Computing dual run lets you replicate
your Mainframe workload in Google cloud
and run the two environments in parallel
this allows you to confirm successful
operations in Google Cloud
before your cutover which can massively
reduce risk
managed instance groups or migs with
auto scaling use application metrics to
radically simplify and improve
operational efficiency allowing you to
scale in and out without manual
intervention
and with the power of Google's ml
Mexican predictably scale in and out
based on historical data
these three defining pillars for Google
Cloud infrastructure
transformative
optimized and easy
are the key tenets behind our
intentional engineering efforts this is
why so many customers trust Google Cloud
and what helps to power such Innovation
across the industry
I invite you to try Google cloud and our
Innovative new releases we look forward
to delighting you
thank you
[Music]
my name is Amar Gandhi a senior director
of product management from Google cloud
and I'm joined by my colleague Jerome
Sims IMR
and we're both excited to share with you
some new products and capabilities we're
introducing at next this year as Amar
said I'm Jerome Sims director of product
management at Google and I'm focused on
Google's devops portfolio it's great to
be here with Amar to share these
exciting updates with our devops
assistant men and operator friends now
Amar will kick off the session
at Google Cloud our mission is to
accelerate every organization's journey
to digitally transform the business and
when it comes to devops we serve
customers of all sizes and types today
and our goal is to make devops on Google
Cloud easy for your organization as well
and to fulfill this Mission we focus on
four key areas which address the key
challenges we hear from these customers
every day
first is security
in devops has become increasingly
critical and we are seeing more and more
hackers preying on the security
vulnerabilities of your software supply
chain today number two multi-cloud
more and more organizations are adopting
multi-cloud today and your devops teams
are being asked to support such
multi-cloud deployments however this is
not easy
how do we ensure efficiency security and
consistency as we develop deliver and
deploy across multiple clouds this
becomes a critical challenge
number three sustainability
given the global climate change
all organizations are rising to the
challenge now Google has long been a
Pioneer in achieving sustainability in
our internal operations and now we want
to provide tools to support sustainable
development and operations for all
organizations
and finally
integrating and scaling your devops tool
chain
this is still a challenge for many
organizations
and to fulfill this Mission we focus on
four key areas which address the key
challenges we hear from these customers
every day this year we are launching
many new products and capabilities
across all of these four areas and now
I'm going to hand over to my colleague
Jerome to tell you more thanks Samar
let's dive into some details of our
announcements today to help you better
protect your software Supply chains
we're very excited to bring you software
delivery Shield
software delivery Shield is a
comprehensive yet modular set of
capabilities that spans a set of Google
Cloud products delivering a fully
managed end-to-end solution to help
protect your software supply chain to
help you better secure your applications
during development we are launching
Cloud workstations
a new service which provides a fully
managed local development environment on
Google cloud with built-in security
measures more than that we are also
giving your developers tools to help
them code faster with greater security
with Cloud code Source protect
developers will get real-time security
feedback as they work in their IDE when
your developers are coding in Cloud
workstations artifact registry and
container analysis can give them a
secure space to store and manage their
container images and language packages
and also scan them for vulnerabilities
you can now do unpush scanning for Maven
and go packages in containers and for
non-containerized Maven packages as well
to help you improve the security of your
open source dependencies our assured
open source software service provides
over 250 packages across Java and python
it also includes verifiable salsa build
provenance in continuing to help secure
your pipelines I'm really excited to
announce Cloud build our fully managed
continuous integration platform now
supports salsa level 3 bills
finally
to help secure the runtime environment
we're introducing a new set of security
features in gke gke can now help assess
your container security posture and give
you active security guidance it also
includes many out of the box security
capabilities for customers on cloud run
our serverless platform we're
introducing new enhancements to Cloud
runs security panel it now displays
software supply chain security insights
such as the salsa build level compliance
information build Providence and
vulnerabilities found in running
services
when your developers are building
application oftentimes they will need
databases I'm happy to introduce Cloud
SQL security recommender with security
recommender it can now automatically
monitor the security posture of your
databases alert you on potential
security vulnerabilities and also
provide guidance to help mitigate the
risks to make multi-cloud easier for you
we're introducing a set of new features
to our anthos platform anthos customers
can now enjoy a unified management
experience everywhere from a single
Google Cloud console
and to drive consistent security
governance and observability across a
fleet of clusters spanning all
environments in addition ansos now
supports VM deployments for your Edge
environments sustainability has been a
core value of Google from the very
beginning and to help our customers
develop and operate more sustainably I'm
pleased to announce that carbon
footprint is now generally available
carbon footprint introduces a new level
of transparency to support you in
meeting your climate goals integrating
and scaling your devops tool chain is a
challenge for many devops teams and for
that I'm happy to announce our managed
service for Prometheus is now GA with
this service there is no longer a need
to Federate ad resources manually or
devote time to maintaining your
monitoring infrastructure you can focus
on scaling your business and not
Prometheus
in addition to make continuous
deployment easier for you we added
integration between Cloud deploy our
fully managed continuous deployment
service and Cloud run our leading
serverless runtime environment
log information is very useful for our
devops teams and to make the use of logs
easier on Google Cloud I'm excited to
announce log analytics a new feature of
cloud logging through an Innovative
partnership with bigquery Cloud logging
now allows your devops teams to get more
value out of the logs through the power
of SQL queries well everyone that's
everything I have today our teams work
super hard to bring you all these new
products and capabilities and I hope
you're as excited about them as I am now
let me pass it back to Amar
thanks Jerome for sharing those exciting
announcements with us
with these capabilities your
organization can adopt a more secure
intelligent and sustainable devops
practice on behalf of Jerome and I we
hope you have a great next 2022.
[Music]
my name is Sunil Podi and I'm the VP and
general manager for Google Cloud
security
as many of you know organizations large
and small are realizing that digital
transformation and the changing threat
landscape
requires a ground-up security
transformation
attackers tactics techniques and
procedures have evolved as their targets
have shifted and the desired outcomes
have changed long gone are the days of a
limited number of malicious nation-state
actors only targeting specific
governments or critical infrastructure
these days New Normal is persistent
attacks and off-the-shelf attack tooling
leveraged by sophisticated threat actor
gangs and nation states
and these folks are primarily focused on
financial gain and business disruption
across the mainstream Enterprise from
the mid-market credit union bank to a
very large Enterprise in the fortune
500. as a new member of Google Cloud
family Manny it brings expertise and
threat intelligence and Consulting to
double down on Google's commitment to
security and management threat
intelligence were always Vigilant
tracking threat actors across the Cyber
domain as they seek to spy steal and
sabotage the networks of organizations
around the world while cyber attacks
used to play out completely behind
closed doors the threat has changed
we're seeing an enormous amount of
activity in full public view State and
criminal adversaries aren't just quietly
hacking victims they're creating public
spectacles which are designed to
undermine The credibility of
Institutions and companies despite
rumors to the contrary ransomware is not
dead those actors are still going strong
but the nature of their activity is
always changing Manny and Google cloud
share a strong commitment to security
and will work together to keep our
customers Defenders and the entire
Global Community safe thanks Sandra I'm
so excited that you and the mandian team
alongside the threat and tell team are
joining Google Cloud
now as many of you know mandian clearly
shares our mission to reinvent how
Enterprises detect and respond to
threats and incidents mandian's products
services and expertise
will all combine to enhance our Google
Cloud security portfolio
and amplify our joint mission to keep
customers safe
now here at Google Cloud we continue to
Champion invisible security to help you
move from today's reality
where security is bolted on as an
afterthought to a future where Cloud
security is engineered in operations are
simplified and shared responsibility
evolves to a model of shared fate where
the cloud provider has two skin in the
game now as many of you know mandian
clearly shares our mission to reinvent
how Enterprises detect and respond to
threats and incidents we are bringing
the best of Google to Enterprises with
Security Solutions for your on-prem
private or multi-cloud environments
and we are helping organizations address
these top of Mind security initiatives
across a variety of dimensions
starting with Cloud governance and
digital sovereignty now as most of you
know digital sovereignty has become top
of mind for many of you internationally
governance and sovereignty are Global
issues with regulations and many unique
compliance requirements
so the core of Google's and Google
Cloud's approach is putting at Carbon
controls in your hands another area that
needs to be reimagined by the CSO and
the entire security team is security
operations all up across all your
environments cloud and on-premises and
on this journey instead of having siled
Sim and soar and threat Intel Solutions
our new Google Cloud Security operation
solution converges security operations
capabilities so that security teams can
now pivot faster and manage alerts more
effectively between Chronicle Sim store
and our Best in Class thread Intel
and with the addition of mandians
leading in incident response Services
in-depth threat intelligence gained from
the front lines and mandian's Advantage
platform
all of these will collectively help us
accelerate your security operations
transformation
this combined approach
will help organizations move from not
just modernizing security operations to
a state of proactive cyber defense
which ultimately we believe is the
future of security operations
transforming security for me
is all about how security can be a
business enabler while making sure the
team Embraces change and leverages all
the latest Cloud native security
controls available to us
to transform our security program we are
really focused on three key areas
security transformation to support
business growth zero trust by default
and threat detection and response going
Cloud native so we've made significant
investments in our Beyond Corp Alliance
alongside strategic Partners such as
Palo Alto and a bad idea of other
partners in the ecosystem this now gives
you comprehensive zero trust options
to secure private and SAS app access
while mitigating internet threats across
managed or unmanaged devices so now we
know implicit trust that we've covered
so far
can create you know an opportunity for
Insider threat management and other
significant security risks not only in
the context of access but also the
software supply chain
in my mind that's the last Green Space
of potential opportunity to to be really
reimagined within an Enterprise security
posture and to further help Enterprises
secure software Supply chains we are
introducing an all-new offering called
software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield
takes this complex challenge with a
tested approach based on best practices
that we use internally
and to secure our own software Supply
chains for a hundred thousand plus
developers here and so to double click
on a specific area we have made
significant progress on assured open
source software very excited to announce
the preview for assured open source that
now provides access to the same open
source software packages that Google
depends on allowing you to benefit
directly from Google's own in-depth
end-to-end OSS best practices so in
addition to everything I just covered
we are also releasing a wide variety of
Innovations across our entire security
portfolio now we are so excited to help
you become like Google with our most
trusted cloud and by bringing security
magic to you wherever you are as our two
fundamental pillars of cloud security
here at Google
and one thing I wanted to highlight was
that in this journey of modernizing
security either on gcp or wherever you
are unlike some of our peers we are
chosen to actually offer best-in-class
partner capabilities
in conjunction with first party Google
Solutions in a cohesive experience
versus an All or Nothing capability
so in closing you may recognize that the
pace of innovation
on this path to Invisible security has
not slowed down
in fact if anything
it has continued to accelerate
especially with mandiant now in the mix
so I hope you'll join us and our
partners on this journey as we reinvent
security to meet the requirements of
tomorrow
thanks again stay secure and have a
great rest of next
[Music]
hello everyone it is an honor to kick
off this session as the new leader for
the Google workspace business
some of you are current customers who
use workspace every day at work and some
of you are considering it for the first
time regardless of which Camp you're in
every time that you use Gmail or Google
Chat calendar Drive dogs meet in your
daily life you are using workspace
bridging communication and collaboration
across these products is the magic of
workspace
I've been leading the development of
these products for the past few years
and it has been remarkable to see that
workspace has become the world's most
popular productivity tool
relied on by more than 3 billion users
across the planet our mission is to
meaningfully connect people so they can
create build and grow together first
let's acknowledge that meetings are not
going away
but they can be dramatically improved to
make the most of meetings we've
introduced features like automatic light
adjustments and noise cancellation so
that you can look and sound your best
companion mode gives everyone a front
row seat and hybrid meetings whether
they're joining from their phone or from
a conference room
and to reduce digital fatigue we've
added features like co-presenting and
the ability to unpin your own video tile
with smart canvas we are taking
real-time co-creation to that next level
by making docs come alive
a simple ad mention in a document can
bring in recommended people meetings and
data to create a flow which allows teams
to stay focused instead of switching
between tools and tabs millions of
customers have already made the move to
workspace and I'm so inspired by their
stories let me share just three of them
Korean Air carries more than 27 million
passengers in a given year
they adopted workspace in July 2019.
to improve internal collaboration and
communication such as more fluid
exchanges between teams and Leadership
they overhauled everything from email
document collaboration and internal
communication we first started by
adopting drive and Google Docs and
eventually replaced all their legacy
tools every month they host more than a
hundred and fifty thousand meetings in
Google meet ranging from just a few
participants to hundreds
they have capitalized the seamless flows
from Google docs to chat to me in
workspace allowing their teams to get
work done no matter where they are
attracting and retaining Talent is top
of mind for many of us as we prepare for
tomorrow's Workforce a new study stated
that's 75 of recent college graduates
prefer working in Google workspace there
are thousands of Engineers across Google
working to deliver on the workspace
mission every year we double the pace of
innovation
this year alone we delivered over 300
powerful new features to help teams get
things done but there's so much more to
come and today I'm excited to announce
new ways in which we're making workspace
even more powerful capabilities like
adaptive framing give everyone in a
crowded conference room a chance to be
seen we've also introduced Auto
transcriptions in Maine not just in
English but soon in French German
Portuguese and Spanish
today I'm excited to share the
web-bringing smart canvas to more places
in workspace starting with Google slides
with speaker Spotlight in slides we're
bringing the Storyteller and the story
together from far more integrated
engaging view creating focus and
engagement I am thrilled to announce
that we're opening up smart canvas for
third-party applications new smart chips
for Salesforce zendesk figma and other
partners will allow people to view and
engage with this Rich third-party data
in the flow of the work rather than
switching tabs or context our
groundbreaking client-side encryption
feature allows customers to have
complete control over access to their
data today we're excited to announce
that we are extending client-side
encryption to Gmail and Google Calendar
we're introducing apis for meet and chat
and I meet add-on SDK that allows you to
bring the power of these tools directly
into the third party apps that you're
using every day
our partners figma and Asana are using
that new SDK to embed their apps
directly into meet
the new figma add-on will enable teams
to collaborate on figma design files and
fig Jam digital whiteboards directly in
Google me
and finally we're bringing app sheet and
Google Chat together so that users can
interact with custom app sheet apps
right within the chat that they're
already using I am psyched by how we can
help users and customers today and I'm
so excited by where we're headed thank
you everyone for joining us we hope you
check out the on-demand content and the
breakout sessions for much more on
workspace bye for now